[Musica]
15 ottobre 2020
mi sveglio con una notifica su twitter o
seriamente bisogno di tutti i miei
contatti grossi di twitter per venire a
capo di una sciarada che coinvolge
mediaset paperissima laga bimba è una
costumista calabrese che si caga addosso
in diretta a quanto pare è successo
qualcosa con una misteriosa gabibbo di
cui io non ero a conoscenza
tutto parte da reddit con qualcuno che
si chiede se sia mai esistita
effettivamente una gamba
avrete sicuramente familiarità con
l'effetto mandela sono quei ricordi
vividi che alcune persone hanno ma che
in realtà non sono mai accadute per
esempio se l'omino del monopoly ha o non
ha un monocolo oppure da cui è tratto il
nome se nelson mandela è morto o no nel
suo periodo di prigionia ed è da qui che
si parte da un ricordo
qualcuno ha in mente l'immagine di una
gamba di una versione femminile del
gabibbo questo argomento interessa a
pochi
ma c'è una risposta in particolare che
desta l'attenzione di tutti ciao italy o
una storia triste da raccontarti è la
storia di g
un mio amico una persona per lo più
normale se si eccettua un particolare è
il figlio di colei che stava nella
gabibbo la storia è questa
a quanto pare l'attrice che interpreta
la gabibbo
negli anni 90 ebbe una crisi dopo i
primi episodi il personaggio non andò
bene con il pubblico
lei per disperazione si presenta una
delle puntate di paperissima ubriaca
tanto che durante le riprese si defeca
nel costume e da quel momento in poi
sono state cancellate tutte le tracce
della suddetta da allora il mio amico è
chiamato nella cerchia più stretta
figlio diga bimba e io credo che presto
si suiciderà c'è un buon 99 per cento di
possibilità che questa storia sia finita
ma per come sono fatto io questo è solo
l'inizio
ho provato a scavare nei meandri
dell'abisso del trash della televisione
per capire se realmente sia esistito
questo personaggio
la cosa principale e cercare prove
effettive dell'esistenza di questo
costume e d'oro compreso il motivo di
questo canale
la ricerca più banale gabibbo gabibbo
paperissima 30 curiosità e aneddoti per
i 30 anni del gabibbo quello un buon
punto di partenza per forza di cose
perché le altre mie ricerche negli anni
del gabibbo si riducono a gabibbo
balotelli per cercare la più grande
black face della storia televisiva
italiana
nel 97 in occasione delle elezioni del
collegio del mugello ha fondato il
partito del gabibbo e non è una presa
per il culo c'è un intervista di antonio
ricci che spiega questa cosa molto molto
vera ed è anche numero 17
l'unico pupazzo televisivo ad aver vinto
un telegatto
ma noi siamo qua per la numero 18
nei primi anni 90 all'interno del
programma paperissima e mondo gabibbo è
apparsa in alcune occasioni la gabibbo
ovvero la moglie del gabibbo
sfogliando l'archivio di adn kronos del
22 dicembre del 1994
mi trovo davanti ad una sinossi di una
puntata di paperissima e per la prima
volta sugli schermi il nostro eroe di
striscia la notizia presenterà la
gabibbo ecco il punto di svolta di cui
avevo bisogno
la gabibbo non è un effetto mandela
esiste ed è incredibile a dirsi ma ogni
tanto internet non basta come fonte di
informazione perché ci sono determinate
cose che nate prima dell'avvento del
world wide web vanno perdute e l'unico
posto dove poterle ritrovare e la
cantina di alcune persone una testa del
gabibbo parlante che potrebbe dare
qualche informazione in più ma purtroppo
non funziona
probabilmente l'acido delle batterie gli
è finito direttamente dentro nella
calotta cranica il vinile ti spacco la
faccia con i grandi classici come ti
spacco la faccia mix version ti spacco
la faccia a cappella version ti spacco
la faccia single version e testo di
pesto tiramolla del 18 giugno 1991 una
sua intervista esclusiva alla scoperta
del gabibbo ce l'hai una mamma cielo si
una mamma è anche un papà heidi e topo
gigio
questo spiegherebbe molte cose on and
off farebbe molte più domande rossi
molto quando dormi
ma quale dormire io sono come totò
schillaci non riesco a chiudere occhio
il gabibbo con l'attrice serena grandi
in paperissima sprint
sarebbe un po come avere una fotografia
di juan con francesca cipriani e
purtroppo neanche qui c'è nulla di
interessante
la svolta però è arrivata con lo zaino
del gabibbo della gabibbo family
padre madre figlia figlio e cane questa
sarebbe la prima vera prova visiva
dell'esistenza della gabibbo anni fa
fecero dei carri allegorici sulla
gabibbo family ma a parte far avere
degli incubi a dei poveri bambini non
era niente di ufficiale
fino ad adesso la fisionomia aberrante
di questa creatura spiegherebbe l'avere
come genitori heidi e topo gigio 6
dicembre 1991 corriere dei piccoli
intervistai gabibbi ora è ufficiale per
davvero
ed eccole qui le immagini ufficiali
della bimba come potete notare in
nessuna fotografia si vede l'interno del
costume in compenso c'è un'immagine
della pimpa ed ecco che arrivano le
informazioni la gabibba gelosa
dell'intervista a suo marito subito
interviene dicendo qualcosa di sé sono
napoletana e scopiazza per i dolci e ho
incontrato il mio gabibbo in una
pasticceria a quando le nozze chiede
l'ingenua intervistatrice se lo chiedi
di nuovo ti spacco la faccia
de luca noi non siamo neppure fidanzati
io vorrei esserlo lo amo così tanto ma
lui guarda solo la sicilia
quindi tutte le prove che abbiamo visto
finora sulla gabibbo potrebbero a essere
false b potrebbe esserci più di una
gabibba in circolazione ma purtroppo le
tracce e le prove di questi fatti sono
andate perdute nel tempo e molto
probabilmente ci hanno anche cagato
dentro
[Musica]